this is the story of the man who helped
turn conservative evangelicals into a
political force I want to talk a little
bit about how much our family respects
and admires Paul Wyrick I want to be
like Paul Wyrick when I grow up
Paul Wyrick has been called the main
architect of the religious right here he
is in 2005 those people were not active
in politics and I served as sort of a
coach to get them active in the
political process he also co-founded
conservative think tanks like the
Heritage Foundation and the Free
Congress foundation and he managed to
galvanize the evangelical vote around a
man who wasn't even an evangelical that
feel familiar because a similar thing
happened in 2016 with the election of
President Donald Trump 2 Corinthians
right 2 Corinthians 3:17 that's the
whole ball game is that the one is that
the one you like I think that's the one
you like is I loved it hey fam I'm a
Mayan and this Sunday we're going to
look at the man behind the evangelical
political movement and how it was an
abortion that created the religious
right in the United States
[Music]
you might have been told that the
movement began with roe v-- wade but
according to Randall Ballmer a religious
historian it actually began with Paul
Wyrick one of the most cherished myths
of the religious right is that this is a
movement that got his origins in
reaction to the roe v wade decision it's
a great story it's been repeated many
many times it is also other fiction
it was Wyrick scalpel aided effort that
made the religious right a political
force and his plan took years to
complete conservatives were wandering
around lost in the liberal wilderness
and then Paul wiry came to Washington
when Wyrick arrived in Washington DC in
the late 1960s he was to the right of
more liberal Republicans which made him
a minority was in his own party
back then the worlds of religion and
politics were largely separate but
Wyrick was determined to change that by
courting white evangelicals the group
had retreated from politics after the
so-called Scopes Monkey Trial in 1925
which really centered around teaching
evolution in schools not only did white
evangelicals lose but they also were
humiliated in the public eye Paul Iraq
according to his own account had been
trying since the 1964 presidential
campaign to get evangelicals active in
politics he tried everything he said he
tried the school prayer issue he tried
the abortion issue he tried pornography
in the end Wyrick landed on school
segregation in the south some carried a
doll in a miniature coffin an effigy of
federal judge Kelly Wright who lauded
the admission of five Negro girls to
formally was Braves in New Orleans last
week and I have to give you a little bit
of a backstory first so please stay with
me in 1970 public schools in seven
states were racially segregated this was
over a decade and a half after the US
Supreme Court ruled segregated schools
were unconstitutional
with its Brown versus Board of Education
decision and Mississippi was one of the
state's fighting hardest against
integration state leaders claimed that
their freedom of choice system allowed
black children to attend white schools
in reality black families were subject
to intimidation if they tried to enroll
and some white families were so opposed
to integration that they abandoned
public schools altogether and home
County Mississippi there were no white
students left in the public school
system after just two years of
desegregation so where were they all
going well between 1966 and 1970 the
percentage of private schools in the
state rose and the number of students
attending those schools tripled most of
this growth occurred in black majority
districts there were segregation
academies church-sponsored
that we're applying for tax-exempt
status then in 1969 a group of
african-american parents in Holmes
County sued the Treasury Department to
prevent three new segregation academies
from getting that tax-exempt status and
they want the court ruled that any
organization that engages in racial
segregation or racial discrimination is
not by definition a charitable
institution the following year President
Richard Nixon ordered the IRS to enact
new policy denying exemptions to all
segregated schools in 1971 the green V
Connelly district court case ruling
upheld the new IRS policy and
evangelical leaders didn't like it which
is where Paul Wyrick re-enters our story
Paul Wyatt finally found the issue that
would get the attention of people like
Jerry Falwell who had his own
segregation academy in Lynchburg
Virginia Bob Jones jr. Bob Jones
University and a broader array of
evangelical leaders Wyrick and far well
managed to shift the grounds of the
debate they turned it into a
conversation about government
interference and religious freedom
instead of what it really was a defense
of racist policies they use the issue to
attack Democratic president and
evangelical Jimmy Carter even though it
was Republican President Richard Nixon
who came down hard on segregation
academies Bob Jones University lost its
tax exemption status a year and the day
before Carter was inaugurated
so Wyrick had figured out how to win
over evangelical leaders but to win
elections he still needed an issue to
get grassroots evangelical voters to the
polls
he realized that defending racial
discrimination might not be it now this
is where the abortion debate comes in
here's Falwell in 1982
but pause bomber says evangelical
leaders didn't pursue abortion as an
issue right away jerry falwell by his
own admission did not preach against
abortion until February of 1978 more
than five years after the Rovio a
decision in 1973 the key moment for
abortion comes in the 1978 midterm
elections Wyrick then resolved that he
would go out and elect some improbable
people why was through all his effort
into getting anti-abortion Republican
candidates elected in Minnesota and Iowa
final weekend of the campaign pro-lifers
leaflet at church parking lots and two
days later in an election with a very
low turnout all four Democratic nominees
lost to pro-life Republicans that's
where why Rick realized abortion was the
issue he could use to bring evangelicals
to the polls and maybe even turn them
against one of their own President Jimmy
Carter before he was elected Jimmy
Carter was a Southern Baptist Sunday
school teacher and what does the Lord
require of thee but to do justly and to
love he embodied the idea of progressive
evangelicalism and won the presidential
election in 1976 in 1979 Falwell created
a group called the moral majority but
the term was actually coined by Wyrick
the more majority declared war on
abortion and homosexuality then the
group enlisted the help of Francis a
Schaeffer Schaeffer worked with C
everett Koop to produce a series of
films called
whatever happened to the human race and
toured the country screening them for
evangelical audiences here's what the
film's looked like the fact that human
life is being devaluated is demonstrated
by some of the major issues which are
being debated by society today abortion
infanticide euthanasia
that series of films begins to travel
and circulate across North America
evangelicals become finally attuned to
the abortion issue in advance of the
1980 presidential campaign Ronald Reagan
courted conservative evangelicals and he
won their support despite the fact that
he signed the bill making it easier for
women to have abortions back when he was
with Governor of California
here he is employing explicitly
religious language in his acceptance
speech can we begin our crusade join
together in a moment of silent prayer
Reagan is a man who wasn't even a
regular Church attending
yet during his presidential campaign he
spoke to 10,000 evangelicals at a rally
in Dallas Texas he talked about the
unconstitutional regulatory agenda
directed by the IRS against independent
schools aka segregation academies he
mentions creationism he also mentions
the Internal Revenue Service going after
the tax-exempt status of segregation
academies he does not mention abortion
in the course of that speech so even as
late as August 1980 the Republican Party
was not sure that abortion would work
for them as a political issue listen
there are a number of reasons Reagan won
the election but he very well might have
tapped into something that Trump in
Steve Anand utilized decades later in
the 2016 election 81% of white
evangelicals voted for Donald Trump man
who least on the face of it does not
seem to be a logical representative for
Family Values Kevin Giles have been able
to persuade at least themselves that
they are victims of some sort of
religious discrimination Christian it's
under siege farmer also says there are
parallels between the beginnings of the
religious right and the rhetoric that
Donald Trump used during his
presidential campaign the 2016 election
allowed the religious right finally to
circle back to the founding principles
of their move
and the founding principles sadly enough
our racism and racial segregation hey
guys thanks so much for watching don't
forget to Like share and subscribe and
if you want to learn more about
evangelicals in the United States
check out the piece that we did on
evangelicals of color and the fact that
they're totally excluded from the news
media's narrative join us next Sunday
for another awesome video bye